Now I want to consider the contents of the page table
entries, at least the entries at the leaves of the hierarchy. In
our example where we had a 32-bit physical address space, it
would be typical to have a page table entries also of 32
bits. With 4k pages, only 20 bits would be needed for
the physical page frame. What do we do with the other 12
bits? Well it turns out that there's lots of other information worth
storing in the page table. Some of the more important are things
like access control. Do we have read, write, or execute
permissions on this memory? If we don't, then when we
come to this page entry, an access violation or segmentation
fault will occur. Another essential piece of information is whether
the information associated with the virtual address is actually in
memory at the moment. It may be the data that
we need was not loaded on the application's start-up or
it may have been swapped out to disk. In either
of those cases, the valid or the present bit would be
zero. When a process tries to access a page with a valid
bit of zero, it creates a page fault and let's the OS
try to bring the needed data into memory. We'll look at the
page fault handler next. One of these bits also indicates whether
the page is dirty. That is, has it been written to since
it was loaded for disk? If not, then if it becomes necessary
to evict this page from memory, there is no need to write
it to disk if it's already there. A nice
optimization. Sometimes a bit or two will also control
how caching of this page is done. Page table
entries corresponding to virtual addresses that were never mapped
to a physical address by the OS usually have
physical frame numbers of zero. The physical frame number
of zero is rather like a null pointer. Everybody
knows that that's an invalid physical frame number and a
segment fault will be generated.